hey las vegas now it's nutrition month
so it's a great time to rethink your
meals and snacks today i have simple
tips and recipes to level up your
nutrition starting with breakfast an
easy way to do that is with the bare
organics high quality usda certified
organic superfood ingredients make chia
pudding with three tablespoons of barrel
organics chia seeds one tablespoon of
beer organics coconut palm sugar and 3 4
cup of almond milk let it sit for 10
minutes before topping with fruit
upgrade your oatmeal with bare organics
acai powder acai berries are rich in
free radical fighting antioxidants that
may help slow down the aging process the
beer organics products are non-gmo and
the packaging is recyclable reusable and
bpa free you can find them on amazon and
beerorganix.com next say goodbye to
boring brown bag lunches with easy to
make bento boxes like this hummus and
veggie stuffed pita pocket and no bread
hummus wrap not only is hummus a great
spread or dip it's a nutritious way to
add flavor to salads without using a
sugary high-fat dressing i used fresh
cravings hummus in classic and roasted
garlic but you can get creative and use
the roasted red pepper or even honey
jalapeno the new line of fresh cravings
hummus at smith's and walmart is super
creamy and made with a short list of
high quality whole food ingredients
including chilean extra virgin olive oil
chickpeas and savory tahini next rethink
your snacks while snacking gets a bad
wrap you can absolutely do it in a
healthy way by focusing on protein and
fiber rich foods the ovation foods
chicken sticks have zero sugar plus 20
grams of high quality protein from two
ingredients lightly seasoned 100 chicken
breast and one whole egg from their
innovative egg sensual shelf-stable
whole egg ingredient eggs are one of the
most nutrient-dense foods delivering
over 35 essential vitamins and minerals
and are one of the best single dietary
sources of choline an essential brain
nutrient that recent studies suggest
over 90 percent of americans may be low
in find these snacks at
innovationfoods.com
finally support gut health and immunity
with probiotics probiotics are
beneficial bacteria found in fermented
foods as well as supplements like true
biotics which features research-backed
probiotic strains and spores that are
designed to withstand their journey
through the body to land in the gi tract
where they can support healthy
microbiome diversity in addition to the
capsules and probiotic gummies
trubiotics just launched two new
products probiotic baby drops designed
to help soothe an upset stomach reduce
crying and fussiness and improve sleep
duration in babies as well as the kids
chewable featuring probiotic strains
that have been shown to reduce miss
daycare days due to illness in children
i hope you enjoyed these tips and
recipes you can find them at my website